وجه جديد في سياسة أمريكا الجنوبية
الذي نصب نفسه رئيسًا لفنزويلا
وهناك أوجه تشابه مع
رئيس أمريكي سابق وصولاً إلى شعارات حملته ،
هل يمكننا فعل ذلك ، نعم يمكننا ذلك ،
لماذا يواجه باراك أوباما التحديات التي
لم يضطر باراك أوباما لمقابلة رئاسة فنزويلا أبدًا.
سيلات إينياس لي الذي عقده
منافس نيكولاس مادورو وريث
عقدين من التدهور الاقتصادي والاضطرابات الاجتماعية ، ومن بين
هؤلاء المؤيدين
الجمعية الوطنية وآخرين ،
ويطالبون جميعًا بالابتعاد عن
التاريخ الماضي المرسوم في الماضي ، حيث إنه
موجود بالفعل على الأرض  عرض على
الفنزويلي العادي تعتقد والدته بالتأكيد أن
OMI تقول إن أوباما يشمر عن سواعده
ويفعل ذلك أيضًا أن هذه هي الطريقة التي
لا يحبها وهو يقلدها دائمًا ما
أخبرناه وكان الكثير من الناس والكثير
من الأصدقاء يخبروك بأنك تشبه
لا أحد يقول لأوباما ، ما
الذي ساعد مهندس آخر من خلال التدريب في تأسيس
حزب التل الشعبي الذي ينتمي إليه على اليسار السياسي
بالنسبة لأخيه الذي لا يزال محافظًا اجتماعيًا
أخبر ما
رأي أخيك في الأقراط الخاصة بك لأنني أعيش في قانون وحيد القرن
ولكن ليس دونيلي لا يحبها ،
فهو لا يحب الأوشام الخاصة بي ، إما أن
التضخم يزيد عن مليون في المائة هنا
وقد فر ثلاثة ملايين شخص بحثًا
عن عمل و  الطعام حتى الطبقات المتوسطة
التي تعيش بالقرب من الفقر المدقع ، يبلغ راتبي
حوالي أحد عشر دولارًا شهريًا ، لذلك
من الصعب جدًا البقاء على قيد الحياة من ذلك ،
لذا فنحن نعتمد بشكل أساسي على الأصدقاء
والعائلة في الخارج الذين يرسلون البضائع ويرسلون
إلينا وتمكنوا من البقاء على قيد الحياة
ويبدو أن الأجيال الأكبر سنا في فنزويلا
تقبل  مسؤوليتهم عن
فوضى اليوم أنهم يتركون المجال
للسياسيين الشباب الذين يصرون على أنهم
يريدون فقط أن يرعوا فنزويلا إلى ديمقراطية جديدة ،
لذلك سوف يترشح كوانج جيدو
للرئاسة في انتخابات كوان وقد
ناقشت الأمر الذي نريد أن نتذكره
كأولئك.  الذي وضع الأسس التي
أدت إلى التغيير في البلاد
والتي ربما تكون أكبر نقطة بيع لـ Guido في
الوقت الحالي هي الافتقار إلى الطموح الشخصي Sam
Kiley CNN Caracas